I'm Jimmy Paul I'm a assistant professor
at the University of Toronto and also a
faculty affiliate at vector Institute
I'm interested in how to make new and I
was to learn faster because right now
audioletter kind of silly compared to
humans
then with quite a lot of data and a lot
of compute so my research focus or do I
make them faster and how can I
understand the current algorithms that
we apply in deep learning that makes
them work so to me my personal interest
is by building faster learning machines
we can probably tap in some new insight
about how human intelligence works
behind the same right the kind of take a
little peek behind the curtains to
understand what makes us so special to
understand the world around us what gave
us ability to learn the included physics
models and allows us to do like
high-level reasonings about our
long-term plans and short-term plans my
personal belief is that the more
dialogues we have across the disciplines
across the field the better we'll
understand the problem as a whole of how
should we decide as a society to unable
the technology for everyone for me it's
a great opportunities to work on very
foundational research problems where
typically the industry search are very
short term and you're cited in a sense
that we think about two or three years
research program that potentially has a
product on the line where see far to
give me the freedom and able me to focus
on more much more long term research
problems for example AI safety program
and building model-based reinforcement
learning or trying to understand the
theoretical properties of the deep
learning when we use today
you
[Music]